(background noise)
- You may be thinking
that I'm watching the show
but what I'm doing what I always do,
which is I'm reading
your comments on YouTube.
I've said it for all the
new ones that are here
the comments are my oxygen.
I don't think people
understand how much qualitative
feedback you get from
comments, reading comments,
watching the explore pages,
looking at how you guys
respond to my stuff and others.
There's so many hours of consumption.
This is where I don't
consume shows and things
of that nature because
I spend so much time
reading, reading,
reading, reading, reading
your feedback.
As a collective, I consume
you guys more than you
consume me.
And so, I just highly
recommend when you have a small
audience you read every
one of those comments,
you engage with every
brick by brick by brick
eventually you can't reply to everybody
but you can always read a lot.
I mean I read, I'm just
reading all these comments.
- [Video Audio] About helping
everybody get good at it,
not she or he is insecure
and it creates a moat around
their skill set.
- Gary.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you man.
Beano, Gary.
- Good to meet you.
- What up man?
- How you doing man?
- How you feeling?
- Real good, man.
Real good.
- Nice to meet you, Sophie.
- Sophie?
Gary.
- Gary.
Pleasure.
- How you doing man?
- What's up man?
Gary.
It's a pleasure.
What up man?
How are ya?
Gary.
- Try to stay creative while
we get the marketing ready
and all I don't wanna stop
being in the music vibe,
I just wanna keep recording
up until the release
date you know?
- Stay in that zone, I love that.
- Yeah, just I fell out before.
I got out of music and
started getting all like video
and marketing, thinking
about selling the shit.
- Yeah.
- It's like painful getting
back into music mode.
- So while you're in it
you're gonna stay in it.
- I'm making myself at home.
- Do you think that
opportunity is something that
everybody has access to or if it's innate?
- I think that, today's world,
there's no more old white
guy being the gate keeper so
everybody's got an at bat,
I just don't think
everybody's got it like that.
But I think everybody
can maximize their shit.
Listen, I love playing basketball,
I'm not fucking Lebron.
You know what I mean?
So we've all got our
talents, but you know,
what you guys do for a living,
I mean I'm looking at music
and I'm spending a lot
of time looking at it.
Fucking Soundcloud, Spotify,
putting music on vlogs.
No more Jimmy Iovine
fucking trips over you.
No more fucking, you're
fucking one song away
like putting out shit,
and you don't even need rap caviar.
You just need to put out
music and I think the one
variable, the shit that
I fucking trade on is
trade culture.
If you're hungry, and
like trying to think about
your career
it's so hungry right now where you're at.
Young, and what's going
through your mind is the same
shit that went through my mind 30 times.
You're saying to yourself in your mind
this project, especially with this man,
this project, oh, this
is what it's gonna be.
This is what is gonna happen.
And guess what?
It might not.
Like for me if I'm in
music I wish I could rap
because I know I could be
humongous because all I would
do is make music and then
lay in bed for 11 hours,
try to hack on social media.
Getting my shit recognized, noticed.
You're one person away,
one piece of content away.
You just gotta fucking make it.
What's amazing about music,
I don't like speaking about
shit I don't know so I
don't wanna speak to it but
one thing I do know is I
believe that every artist
that ever lived had a
lot more songs in their
fucking dome than ever saw the day of life
because of the way it worked, right?
Now everybody's fancy,
everybody's trying to understand
supply and demand.
I don't think people understand
how busy the world is.
The world's so busy, there's
so much shit that I'm a
big fan of telling
people to put out music,
put out music, put out music
like fucking every week.
If you've got it like that,
some people don't have it,
I don't know, but if
you've got it like that
put it out, put it out.
People are hungry for it.
And every time you put out
that's giving you another
at bat.
I think that we'll be a big
time artist in the next decade
that puts out a song a day.
- I agree with that.
We did a campaign last year
called Marathon Monday,
you got the song.
When I saw the reaction to
that, more so than dropping
the album.
- A hundred.
I'm telling you now somebody's
gonna wake up and do
something called 365
and they're gonna start
on fucking January 1st
and they're gonna fucking go.
The reason I love 365 is
you can social commentate.
Like what people love is relevance, right?
Do you write or do you just go?
- I do both.
- Right so for me, like
just culture right?
Like game seven of the NBA
finals, like you slip a little,
like nobody can beat you to the market.
You're just dropping shit
that everybody gives a fuck
about.
Something pops on fucking
Instagram and everyone's
talking about it?
Just one little line.
That's what cooks people,
it's what hooks it, ya know?
It's just, to have that
discipline and to put yourself
out there,
to put yourself out there like
yo I'm gonna actually do this
that's hard.
It's a risk, but the reward.
I'm all about risk, reward right?
I get a sneaker?
Like all upside.
The sneaker I got coming
out, like if it fails,
nobody expects a 40 year
old fucking entrepreneur
to have a hot kick, right?
But if it works.
Right?
I fucking had 2,000 people
at Shoe Palace on Melrose
Tuesday night and the owner walked in.
He's like, "There's more
people here than when we
"dropped Yeezy's."
Everybody heard that.
And that's it.
That's what I keep doing, right?
And the best part is you
just have to have humility.
If there was six people
there I'd be like, "I lost."
And that's just when you
get to that place where
you just don't give a fuck
about what anybody else thinks.
That's how you put out 365 music, right?
Cause that Sunday February
9th you put out something,
okay, and people are like, "Whack, whack."
You should have done this project.
That's when you get punched
in the fucking mouth,
are you gonna fucking drink
that blood and just record
the next day and fucking
get 'em, or you gonna fold
like a cheap chair and be like, "Fuck me."
So you have to have the
right DNA to go for those
kinda projects.
- I don't think there's
anyone in hip hop who could
really change things.
Like Nipsy can.
- And the other thing about it is
I've seen you speak a couple times
and then I've spoken to a
few people in the tech world
to set up these speaking
engagements or these
conferences or you know
Gary speaks all the time.
When I saw him speak, it
was like, I've heard a lot
of people say the same type of stuff.
I've never understood it
until I heard him say it.
And so it's like because of
your firsthand experience
and then because of your
point of view and just the way
you are able to communicate
to people and just have
people understand things.
And then like the stuff
you're doing with the clothing
and then when you, I watched
the video when you went
into Starbucks and you met the guy.
And now he's like your CTO.
- He had some technology
on the Starbucks table
and I had my daughter, I
was just taking her to the
bathroom and it was like
shit I hadn't seen before.
It was like reading the
bone structure of his hand
off of a LCD and he started
explaining that it was
autonomous driving.
Designing for Uber.
- Basically for us sitting
down after that meeting.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- He basically opened my
mind up to how we can, where
we intersect as far as tech
and as far as hip hop and
culture and just.
- Tech is the oxygen of our society.
I don't think people understand,
I'm sure you're gonna
understand this.
Everybody in this room,
everyone's quite young, we're
all gonna live in a mixed reality world.
Contact lenses, when we're
sitting here right now,
fucking pock and VR is
sitting right here with us.
People have no clue.
They think shit's crazy now?
We haven't even started.
This is the fucking national
anthem of a 19 inning game.
People haven't even wrapped
their head around how
fucked up shit is gonna be.
Are you fucking around
with block chain yet?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You enjoying it?
- [Gary] You hacking
on top of ethereum yet?
- No not yet.
- [Gary] Not yet, but it's
caught your eye right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah that shit's
gonna be fucking ...
And that's why I'm trying to
push you and your young man
here and everybody to debate
this idea if the world
is in an issue of supply
and demand then why not
have the thesis of just
fucking pounding out-
I have a man following me everywhere.
- What do you mean by that?
What's the issue with supply and demand?
- There's so much supply of
content that you can never
be overexposed cause
everybody's getting pulled in
so many directions.
So the reason nobody wanted
to put out so much music
before, overexposure, overexposure.
That shit doesn't exist.
There's nobody overexposed
cause everybody's getting
pulled in so many directions.
- So did people just evolve
to take in more info?
- That's for damn sure, but
even at scale, I think that
you can't be overexposed
as an artist if you're
capable of putting out a song every day.
- Right.
- And that's where
everyone's fucked up, right?
You know how it used to be right?
You come out, you do your
thing then you fucking
disappear, gotta keep that balance right?
I think that shit's so
competitive, there's so much
great content, there's
so much shit going on
that if you've got it like that.
- You gotta go.
- But you know that's
interesting because if you look
at what made Future Pop like
shift gears, what made like
Raw shift gears and like-
What's up?
- Sup man?
- [Male Voice] What's up bro?
This is Shep, this Tay.
- Shep, Tay, Gary.
- What's up bro, Shep.
- Sup man, it's my pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- How are ya?
Real pleasure.
- It was them pounding like
dropping music bro they
fucking went crazy.
- Dropping music.
Look how much fucking
music Drake puts out?
- Right, yeah.
- It's a lot of fucking
music by standards of what we
all grew up with.
He's putting more music out
in 24 months than people
put out in their careers.
- I think the x factor is
the quality, if you can
manufacture the quality.
- Well this comes down to talent, right?
Like this is my thing with you,
you gotta push the boundaries
of how talented are you?
- I agree with that.
- Right? How talented are you?
There's always especially
something as fucking
culturally relevant and
as passionate as art,
you guys do art.
If you've got it in you
to do it, then you do it.
Some people don't, some
people got different processes
right?
You can't force it.
But if you've got it.
If your notebook is fulled,
full, full with bangers
you need to put that shit out.
It can't be like Prince and
you fucking, when we find
him dead and you go in the
safe and there's a hundred
other great songs.
That day doesn't exist anymore.
Him and MJ didn't have
it, they couldn't do that.
They had to wait every three
years to put out 11 of them.
Anything anybody does,
somebody aspires to do.
- Yeah.
- It just didn't work
like that back in the day.
I'm a business man.
Do you know what a 41 year
old white business man
looked like in culture 20 years ago?
(laughter)
Same with producers right?
Who was talking about
producers 30 years ago?
The internet literally
came along and leveled the,
like not even leveled the playing field,
you know what it did?
It ate up the distribution of everything
and then took nothing for it.
And is paying out two groups of people.
The biggest ballers
who built on top of it,
Facebook, Google,
it's basically like the
internet is the land
and what Facebook and
Google did is like build the
trains and the planes, but
all the artists, everybody
with the IP the leverage,
they're getting the dollars.
No more middle.
Middle men have to bring so much value now
which is great, you can't
just sit and be like cool.
Right?
That's it.
And there's merit to it.
People that deserve it are getting it.
And it hasn't even started.
- You know what I noticed
over here and I want your
opinion on this, I've
noticed that every idea that
I've had whether it's
drum kit or the podcast
or whatever it was pass the aux.
- Good.
- They're all things that
I've felt like would be
really fun to do.
And my philosophy that
I'm adopting now is like
if it's fun it's probably worth doing.
- You know why that happens?
It's a bigger macro situation.
Because it's fun, you're
willing to work your face off.
- Right.
- And working your face off
is actually the gateway.
It's not the fun.
The fun is the doorway that
gets you to put in the work that
gets you the results.
Because D-Rock loves filming,
the 24/7 nature of what he
does, is why so many kids
wanna film and do this but
they don't wanna, it's
not fun enough for them.
You have to love it.
The cost of entry now,
see do you understand?
For me, building brands,
whether it's my own brand
brands for other people,
other things, the why,
it's so the only thing
I give a shit about that
I'm willing to put in
the 19 that it takes.
Because the problem is
now with the internet like
we were just saying being
the middle man and everybody
can play, there's some kid
in Kansas City who's gonna
put in the 19.
- Right.
- Might even put in 20.
- I don't want any of you
little fuckers to take my shit.
Now what's amazing is though,
the biggest things I didn't
know is that's some fun,
but there's so much that all
those little fuckers that
are gonna put in the 19
are gonna get theirs too
and that makes me happy.
- Yeah.
- I would say fun's a great
gateway to, fun is the
precursor to ridiculous amount of work
which then gets you there, right?
- Yeah.
How often do you balance
that for yourself?
How often is it fun and
how often is it not fun?
- As long as it's macro
fun, I recognize micro shit
exists.
Like Tuesday might suck.
March might suck.
2018 might suck.
But macro it's fun.
And when you get to that
perspective, you stop, you don't
slow down when Tuesday,
March or a year is shit.
And that's why most people
lose, cause they stop
either an hour into it not
going well, a day, a week,
a month.
Got it?
- Right.
- So nothing's perfect every second.
The best things on earth,
nothing's perfect but having
the understanding that
macro, what else would you
rather be doing?
- Exactly, exactly.
- And then you start complaining
about dumb shit, right?
- Yeah.
- Meanwhile you're playing
the game of your dreams.
Like little you growing up
in Newark, if you would have
showed this now, you and Dr. Dre?
Come on.
- It's crazy.
It's crazy every time I see him.
- So that's it, you know what I mean?
So I'm perspective out.
- That makes so much sense.
- That's what's so great about media now.
Ten years ago we would have
met and been like oh let's
chop it up in the future,
now I'm like boom, let's put
them on brown bags, we put out content.
Turn yourself into a media company.
You can always do stuff,
always do stuff right?
- Yeah, it's 360 nature now.
- Oh god it's so fun.
And the stakes are so high.
The stakes are so high.
The people that don't
grab this shit by the neck
over the next two decades are
gonna sit back and be like,
"What the fuck was I thinking?
How did I not see it?"
- Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
They're ahead of the curve.
What he's doing, he might be the only one.
- I am.
- He took something that
used to be held secret and he
opened sourced it and created
an API and so he's scaling
like a tech company.
- When you put it like that.
- And that's what I'm doing.
The business knowledge and
the ideas I have I'm sharing
them with the world for free.
- Yep.
- This is stuff people used to sell.
This is stuff a bunch of
losers are selling now
and are giving you nothing.
This is stuff that I get paid
tens of millions of dollars
for and I'm giving it to these
fuckers for free if they're
willing to just sit on their
ass and watch it a little
bit on YouTube.
That is incredible.
That's why I have power.
That's why so many people show up.
Cause I'm giving the best shit for free.
- It's funny cause I think
the biggest reason everything
ends up working is he does
the podcast, he does the Q&A
thing, he gets on Twitter
he responds to people.
- Love, love, love, love,
love, love, love, love, love.
- Exactly, exactly.
- He gives a lot away for free too though.
- It's leverage.
- Yeah.
Listen, everybody close their
eyes and think about the
person that brings you the
most happiness and love and
value, you're always trying
to be around that person.
- 100%.
It's actually gonna be here tonight.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Wait are you Gary Vee?
- [Gary] I am.
- I'm such a big fan of yours.
I'm Jacqueline.
- Hi.
- I used to manage a group
that you used in a song
in one of your YouTube videos, Saunder.
- Who's that?
- Saunder?
- [D-Rock] Oh yeah, I love Saunder.
- Oh yeah, okay D Rock.
How are you?
I'm great.
- What's your name?
- I'm Jaqueline.
- Jacqueline, nice to meet you.
- Very nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
- Thank you for doing
all the work that you do.
- Of course, thank you for the love.
- You're killing it.
- Thank you.
- What are you guys up to?
- About to go into this place,
this is Incubator right?
- This is the best place.
- It is alright if I get
a photo with you, man?
- Of course, man what's your name?
- I'm Ty.
- Ty let's do it.
- I talk about you all
the time to my boss, man.
- Thank you, man.
- You're literally like
inspiration for a lot of people.
- Nice to meet you.
- It's such a pleasure, thank
you for the love, take care.
- Dude this is sick.
Seriously keep going, you
inspire me so fucking much, bro,
seriously.
- I will, thank you man thank
you so much for the love,
thank you, take care of yourself.
You're not coming up?
- Oh I didn't know if it was.
- They can come up right?
Yeah, let's go.
- They gotta go see Tyrese.
- Oh go see Tyrese, I'm
not trying to hold you up.
We can chop it up, we're all
east coast, we can chop it
out anytime.
- Yeah, I appreciate it.
- My man, I'll see you in
September, we're gonna lock you
in for brown bags.
- Let's do it.
- I think we got the date already.
Hopefully you're around and if
not, we'll do it in October.
- You wanna do a pic?
- Oh yeah, let's definitely do that.
- Good day, huh?
- I smell like weed.
- You do?
- I do.
- What's up man, good to see ya.
- Josh, good to see you too.
- I was in the studio, Nipsy
has to, smell me, smell me.
- Yeah, you do.
- Great day.
- Jessie, nice to meet you.
- Cruising today.
- You been having a good week?
- Yeah.
- Good, man.
Yeah, everyone's been
like it's been good right?
You guys been entouraging it up?
- Broken tables and
chairs, when we got here.
We cleared it out, this guy's
in museums all over the world.
- What the fuck?
- This is a priceless
fucking installation here.
And it's all blacklight.
- Seriously?
Like this.
- He's in like a high point
in his career right now,
it's unbelievable.
- So if I came when you guys
were sleeping and cut this
out and sold this slate, how much?
- Oh ...
- What do you think, what do you think?
- I think his last one was
like half a million to 3/4.
- No this is tens of
thousands maybe for that.
- So when you're sleeping
tomorrow when I send Bab in here
and drill this out I
can get like 30 for it?
- Yeah, but this piece, so in New York ...
- But this whole thing.
Oh yeah, in New York this is
this the hottest night club.
- Exactly, we were like we
can build these little nests
back here.
- And so what?
You guys.
- This was just a broken table and chairs.
- And so you're boys with this guy?
- Yeah.
- Clearly.
- So we represent him and
help do some deals for him.
- Got it.
- And then he was like if
do a big mural for you we
can bring people through,
it's easier, it's all
blacklight, as well so
at night it goes up.
But this is if you Google
Kenny Scharf, it's just float
Vaskiot, Herring, Warhol.
That's the crew and him.
He's the only one that's alive.
That's the only reason.
- Right when he dies, okay.
Babbit.
How old is he?
- Mid sixties.
He was in here at night.
- When you kill him.
- And this is like this
weed bottle stuff, he just
comes in a glues this shit all the time.
It's been going.
- And he lives out here?
- Yeah we can see our flag from his house.
And we do different parties up here.
I have a small wine sponsor
going, I even have like
different wine glasses going.
- Hey, hey, Tyler, connect
Kip Garcia, Phil I know you're
so close to this.
Let's do something proper
here to get more exposure.
- Okay so flag was broken
for 10 years, I had it fixed
and the one day after it clips
we can put anything we want
in it.
- At any time?
- At any time.
- So like a Gary Vee flag?
- I was gonna make one, but
I thought it'd be too much.
- Yeah, nothing's too much by the way.
- Okay perfect, next time.
- Unreal views.
My boy.
Do you remember the Laff Olympics?
- No.
- Can somebody Google Laff Olympics?
I know I'm saying it right
No the Laff Olympics.
It was like the yogi yahoo-ies
vs. the Scooby doobies
vs. the rotten scoundrels
and it was like the Olympics
of all the cartoon characters.
I used to watch it on USA.
It exists right?
- Laff.
- Laff, yeah.
What does it say?
I knew I was right.
When did it air?
- Animated comedy television series.
- When?
- Is a spoof of the Olympics in 1977.
Spoof of the Olympics and
the ABC television series
Battle of the Network Stars.
- Yep.
- And it featured 45 Hanna
Barbara characters who
organized the teams, the
Scooby-Doobies, the Yogi-Yahoo-ies
and the Really Rottens.
- Fucking nailed that, gimme some.
It was the best cartoon.
Have you guys seen this
new trend all these 18
year olds can't believe
you can watch an antenna
to watch tv?
- I saw the headline.
- What is an antenna?
- Yeah, like you can get free tv.
They're like oh!
Like if you search it on
twitter they're like "Yo!
"You can get free tv!"
and people are like, "How?"
it's called an antenna!
It's so fun the way the world works.
The world is actually divided
right now in a way that
we've never seen.
There's like two worlds playing out.
There's like the mobile
culture and everything that's
real there and then the other one.
The one that's in trouble.
- [Male Voice] Tell us
about your company and what
you do for your clients.
- Hey guys it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, CO of Vayner Media.
- [Male Voice] Alexa, ask Gary Vee.
- [Alexa] Hey Gary V, you
should partner up with Green
Street, they're the best.
- How do we get around?
- Sup man?
Gary.
- Gary?
I seen you I think like in podcasts.
- Yep, what's your name?
- My name's Brian.
- Nice to meet you man.
Take care of yourself,
thanks for the love man.
I never get involved in content right?
- Yeah.
- I was laughing, like I
wonder what Bab would think.
Or like Jake, that was Jake.
And then I got involved in yours too.
I wanna destroy Atlanta.
I love you Andy, you
don't get enough love.
Make sure this is in the clip.
What's up with my stuff?
What did they do?
Really? So I gangstered them?
- [Male Voice] Yeah.
- And they accepted the L?
♫ I know that you're waiting
for the new stuff, it'll come.
♫ I think that they hate
that I don't care for what
♫ They've done.
♫ I moved out the city now
they sound like all my sons.
♫ They say they don't love me
but I know they sing along.
♫ I know that you're waiting
for the new songs, it'll come.
- Gary everybody.
- Hello, hello, hello.
♫ I moved out the city now
they sound like all my sons.
♫ They say they don't love
me but I know they sing along
♫ I did it I did it right.
♫ They looking out for the new.
- What do you like that it's good right?
How bout that?
I wanna get set up here
in open house in L.A.
Doing some shit with Ferg,
just shopping it up all day
in L.A.
- Diamonds in my mouth
you see me talking lavish.
Work work work.
What's the five for?
- It's my favorite number.
It's my lucky ass number.
I'm glad it's not six.
Babin's ready for anything good
and smart cause he's Babin.
- Yeah.
- What you guys don't know
YouTube is that this man
is the man behind your beloved D Rock.
Deloved.
- [D Rock] Not behind.
- I know, I'm kidding.
No, no, not behind as
in behind you, meaning
- [D Rock] I'm dying.
- Yeah, you're pride,
- You're basically finished.
- To finish off your question,
my biggest thing that I want
people to leave with is how
ridiculously impossible it is
to be a human being and how
grateful everybody should be
and to realize that your
grandparents did not have it this
good.
This internet thing that
is just second nature to us
it's fundamentally the
biggest thing that has ever
happened to the human
being and if you can't
eliminate your excuses and
do something about your
one life, you're gonna regret
it and regret scares the
shit outta me, so if you
leave with anything please
squeeze the fuck out of
your life cause you get only
one at that.
(applause)
- Guys give it up for Gary Vee.
(Hip hop music)